WESLEY CHUN: Hey, Alison.
ALISON CARROLL: Hey, Wes.
WESLEY CHUN: How's it going?
ALISON CARROLL: Good.
WESLEY CHUN: Congrats.
I heard you made VP.
ALISON CARROLL: Yeah, thank you.
WESLEY CHUN: Awesome.
Say, what's with
all the receipts?
ALISON CARROLL: I've got one
hour to file my expense report.
I've got to run to
a meeting right now.
It's just so frustrating
I have to spend
all this time doing this.
WESLEY CHUN: I'm sorry.
Hey, I've got this cool tool
I think you should check out.
ALISON CARROLL: Yeah?
WESLEY CHUN: If you go through
all your receipts in Gmail,
there's this little tool
you click on at the bottom.
It pulls in all the
information off your receipt,
like the date, the
amount it was for.
You just plug-in a spreadsheet,
and-- boom-- when you're done,
you'll have an
entire spreadsheet
full of all your
expenses and one place
to do your expense report.
ALISON CARROLL: Really?
That is amazing.
Can you show me how
to use that later?
I've got to run.
WESLEY CHUN: OK.
ALISON CARROLL: But
let's meet up later.
WESLEY CHUN: All right.
Good seeing you.
ALISON CARROLL: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Sometimes
the most powerful of tools
come in small packages.
And today's example
is no exception.
Hello, everyone, and welcome to
another episode of "The G Suite
Dev Show."
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
Today, we're solving a
common business use case
by building a Gmail add-on.
I'm joined by Sundar Solai,
the engineer who built
the tool we'll be discussing.
So, Sundar, what motivated
you to write this app?
SUNDAR SOLAI: One problem we
all try to tackle in our own way
is managing business expenses.
These days, most businesses
send email receipts,
so it's natural to
have a tool for users
directly in Gmail, just
like when you demoed
the add-on to Alison earlier.
WESLEY CHUN: So what's
the add-on again?
Well, it's a mini app
that runs within Gmail.
And that cute little interactive
UI is called the card.
Cards could be as
simple as text dialogs,
but could also include formatted
text, images, links, buttons,
and even forms, like ours.
A variety of widgets are
available to developers.
The best part is that
cards work seamlessly,
whether viewed on the
desktop or on mobile.
SUNDAR SOLAI: The
add-on features
the code that creates the card.
It also powers the
rest of the logic,
including parsing the email
and talking to Google Sheets.
So how does one
create a Gmail add-on?
The secret is
Google Apps Script.
Apps Script is
server-side JavaScript
customized to execute in
Google's Cloud, giving
your apps access to G Suite
data in Drive, Gmail, Sheets,
plus other Google and
external services.
This link takes you to videos
to learn more Apps Script.
WESLEY CHUN: While add-ons
are powered by Apps Script,
they extend the
standard functionality
that everyone gets
in G Suite apps,
like Docs, Sheets,
and now Gmail.
See the blog post
for more information.
The Gmail add-on we're covering
addresses that exact use case
for processing
business expenses.
Sundar, can you give us a
bit more on your add-on?
SUNDAR SOLAI: Sure, Wes.
Our sample app is
called ExpenseIt.
And like you saw with Alison,
it scans the date, amount,
and vendor from email
receipts, presenting
a mini form that's automatically
filled in with details.
Users can edit, if necessary,
then submit those values
to a spreadsheet without
ever leaving Gmail.
Let's walk through some of
the core parts of the add-on
to give you an idea
of how they're built.
Then you'll have
enough knowledge
to build your own when
an idea inspires you.
The first function is
getContextualAddOn.
This is the entry point that's
called to launch the add-on.
Gmail add-ons run on
a per message basis.
So whatever message
you're on, that's
the message ID that's passed
to getContextualAddOn.
Here, with the help of
some utility functions,
the email message is parsed
for the relevant values
from the receipt.
Once we have all the values
in the prefills array,
the UI add-on is built and
given to Gmail to render.
It calls createExpensesCard
to do this.
createExpensesCard creates
the primary UI of the add-on
with the form values
being optional,
so users can edit if
desired, and finally,
a possible submission status.
Because neither
parameter is required,
there's a lot more
flexibility in terms of the UI
that's rendered.
With the same code,
you can have forms
with values but no status,
a status-only text dialog
without form fields, or both.
Due to the size of
the function, we've
left out the optional
status processing code
to focus on the key
components here.
The last function we'll
preview is submitForm.
Once the user
submits the form, we
need to push that data
into a Google sheet.
The first part validates
the form values,
then it adds a new row into
the sheet specified by the URL.
Note we've left out
the error checking code
so as to focus on adding
the expenses to the sheet.
And that's it.
You've now seen the key
pieces of a Gmail add-on.
WESLEY CHUN: Thanks, Sundar.
Want to build ExpenseIt
yourself step-by-step?
Then try our Code Lab that
will help you do just that.
To see what others have
done with Gmail add-ons,
check out the Developers
Showcase Talk at Google
Cloud Next.
SUNDAR SOLAI: If you want
to do some more research
before tackling
the Code Lab, read
the Gmail add-ons overview,
or check out the quickstart
for a shorter code sample.
If you're interested in add-ons
for Docs, Sheets, or Forms,
check out the third link.
WESLEY CHUN: And this
is just the beginning.
Now it's time for you
to use your imagination
to think about how else you can
extend Gmail to solve a problem
or make users more efficient
with Gmail add-ons.
Thanks to Sundar for
stopping by today to help us
walk through his cool app.
ALISON CARROLL: Hey, Wes.
WESLEY CHUN: Hey, Alison.
How's it going?
ALISON CARROLL: Oh, I
love this Gmail add-on.
Thank you so much
for showing it to me.
I did my expense report so fast.
WESLEY CHUN: Sure,
no problem, Alison.
We look forward to seeing what
you build with Gmail add-ons.
This is Wesley Chun from Google.
Thanks for stopping by
"The Dev Show" today.
And we'll see you
upstairs in the G Suite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]